um so um as you i've got i work mostly
uh with um discrete genetic events
and uh things that i like to call that
mixture graphs
uh which i will show you an example of
that most people here will have seen
something like this
and
i want to show
i want to do three things in this talk i
want to show you how to calculate
joint spectra analytically
on a mixture graph
it's easiest to understand what's going
on
uh in a situation
uh where there are no mutations in no
new mutations in the graph what that
means for me is that you're already
polymorphic at the root
and that's the first that's the first
part of the theory you ought to you need
to get
then i want to show you
how you can extend that
to
mutations which arise are more recently
in the root of the tree
that's um
part a i done some time ago part b
i doubt if you've seen
and finally i want to give an
application which is
not
so different from
um
uh lamar's application but i'm gonna go
over it a bit more slow i think
um
now
i would say that i've been actually
working sort of off and on on this for
several years and i still don't regard
the workers mature
there are
lots of technical difficulties some
some of which laura actually mentioned
things like convergence and i don't feel
i have a
a reliable and robust inference engine
that i want to release to to to you yet
um
but so this is very much work in
progress although it's been work in
progress for quite a long time
okay so um i'm not going to try and
formally define that mixture graph but
here here's a fairly complicated example
you've got um a root of the tree uh
where um
you should really think
that there's a constant
you think the root is fairly ancient and
that there's a constant size population
uh more ancient than the root
because i'm not modeling anything there
and then you get there are two sorts of
edges in the graph
and most of them are what i call drift
edges
in which
allele frequencies are simply changing
in frequency by diffusion
down the edge
i'm going to assume
throughout this work that your constant
size population on each edge
right so um uh what that means is that
um
the um
the counter timer what constant size
population you've assumed to determine
the actual drift and then finally
you have
other edges like this
which correspond to admixture events
and
you it's sort of fairly obvious
intuitive what this means but what this
means if you pick a random allele in w
um it has probability alpha of having
instantaneously come from b prime and
probably one minus alpha came from the
other population so this is a point
event happening instantaneously in time
and um the reason i like these events is
not because i think they're
mathematically um that i think they're
they're biologically or historically
correct
it makes the mathematics easier at least
for me
so
this apparatus does not
is not able to deal say with migration
events where you have low level
migration occurring over significant
periods of time that's a different thing
all right so
two sorts of craft edges add mixture and
drift
and i just want to briefly
um to remind you
about some diffusion theory results uh
most of you will know this stuff because
it's not um this is sort of
uh what i can call commuter theory uh
elementary
um
uh
on the right fischer diffusion but here
are some basic facts and notation
so
um the first is the ground rules
i've got um i've got neutrality
everywhere no selection
and no double or back mutations
so
um
any um
uh if you see a derived allele
in two places if there was an ancestral
mutation event
and
that's important
i think this is
not a bad assumption
on genome-wide human data
though there are certainly some
difficulties there
we have an ancestral population
um and this is i'm just trying to give
so imagine you have one age on my tree
so you have an ancestral population x so
descendant population y here's some
drift
um
t generations and the population size is
n
so the um the standard diffusion time
scale uh is you say that the drift time
is tau which is t over two n
so um
uh the on the diffusion time scale a
coalescence occurs at rate one
which is why that we do this
and um i like to write the
transition function for the right
fischer diffusion uh this is your
frequency x
um at
big x your frequency y big y the drift
is tau
and
if you're polymorphic
so uh
y is on the open interval 0 1
this transition function which i call
the camera function
is the uh probability density of your
you are at y conditional on your word x
okay so this is all just basic notation
so
um
some facts about diffusion that we
are using all the time
um diffusion's a markov process
uh
if you know where you are now that
determines the future um and the past is
irrelevant
and the diffusion is a martingale
so the expected value
of the frequency in the future
is the frequency now
um
and um
that's true for all future time
um
then next fact um
you fix out in finite time almost surely
that's um uh
really an important property of the
right fischer diffusion and you actually
need to think about that um it's not um
um it's not um entirely trivial to prove
that at least for me but it's a
important fact
and um i also need repeatedly
um the
classic
uh polymorphic spectrum
for um
a population of constant size
um where what you what i the way you
think about this
is i'm looking now
and um back in time some mutations are
occurring
at um a very small rate
per
per
small time so in some tiny interval
there's a very small
probability epsilon delta delta t
that a mutation occurs
and um
uh i'm interested
in
the probability distribution
uh of the allele frequency now
and uh ewins proved in the 60s
that
if you look at the
i'm assuming i'm polymer polymorphic
here
and you look you integrate over all the
possible times back
back where the mutation could have
occurred and normalized by epsilon
um the spectrum is two over y
so you get this for the for the derived
spectrum so that's analytic and it's
very helpful in some of the other things
that i i'm doing here
all right so um here's some
here's something that
um
most of you
some of you like your song and there
will know this extremely well and uh
people who worked on the fusions know
this result but they probably don't know
it in this exactly presented this way
so um uh
we've got again i just look at one edge
on the tree ancestral population x uh
descendant population y
and um
i'm interested
in expectations
of polynomials in y
so f of y is a polynomial and my
notation is i'm interested in the
expected value of f
conditional on the allele frequency
being x in the parental population
and
so
some facts
this
expected value
e sub x is a polynomial in x
and um i uh want to i just want to get
back to the same space i've got
polynomials in y e x is polynomial and x
so change x to y so get me back to the
same space the map f
going to e sub f is linear
and
if you have a linear map it's natural to
wonder what the eigenvectors are
and the answer is
the eigenvectors are the polynomials 1
y
and then the polynomial is y times 1
minus y times jacobi polynomials
which
are certain a family of orthogonal
polynomials
and of the corresponding eigenvalues are
one one and then this ether minus lambda
right tau
where lambda sub i is this
combinatorial thing i plus one i plus
two over two
now this is a thinly disguised version
of kimura's theorem which gives you an
explicit formula for the transition
function of the right fischer diffusion
so
this is simply kimura's work in the
1950s um mildly repackaged
right um okay
clear enough so far
so
this gives me
the first thing i want to do
is write down a calculus
for um writing down e sub x
right and uh
okay
and so here it is explicitly
um you take so you take your polynomial
f y
um you can write it
um
in this form
you pull out the constant in linear
terms then you're left with a bunch of
stuff that's got to be degree at least
two
um you arrange it that um uh
everything's divisible by um that f of
zero and f of one
are um
uh
uh you arrange f of zero and f of one 1
to
kill
the
behavior at the boundary and then you
get this lifting formula where
the
constant and linear terms just lift
straight off
the linear term lifting is just a
re-statement of the mardi gras property
when you think about it for a
microsecond and then you get this jacobi
polynomial expansion and you have to
multiply by the relevant eigenvalues
this is a completely explicit lifting
formula that allows you to lift any
polynomial back one edge
right
okay
so
um in our mixture graphs
we also have these
admixture
edges
and i'd like to know how to lift that
and this is um completely trivial
um what i'm doing here is i'm just gonna
i've got a polynomial a little u
and i'm interested in lifting that back
to polynomials little s little t
and all i do is i substitute
alpha s plus beta t for u
and again i get a new polynomial in s t
and i've eliminated you
right
so
i told you how to lift the drift edges
i told you how to lift the mixture edges
right
um that's um
uh those are the basic ingredients for
the algorithm we need this is analytic
stuff
all right so now we come back and this
you'll see
um is not millions of miles away from
what laura was doing
i've got a mixture graph
i've got
a whole bunch of what of what i think of
as leaf populations
and the leaf populations
are populations which
i'm thinking of as as populations now
the current populations
and i'm observing counts of the derived
and ancestral alleles are
on the leaf populations
so
um i have a i'm going to introduce
um
a variable x sub i
which um corresponds to the derived
allele frequency in each in each allele
population just for notation y sub i is
1 minus x sub i and so um you have this
binomial formula
for um the probability
of seeing a particular count vector
i see a bunch of count c
the complementary counts of d this is
just binomial theorem for what the
likelihood is
of seeing those counts uh conditional
on
my uh
my
variables at the leaf and
the um what i want to calculate
is a likelihood of these counts
conditional on a frequency
r at the root of the tree
right so um
you know i've got some
mess here
um uh there's a there's a there's a
frequency little r right back here right
huh
um
uh i i ought to be able to calculate um
the the probability of seeing these
counts down here conditional
remember that our ground rules for now
are no new mutations right so nothing
nothing no mutations are rows on this
tree down here
all right and uh
it's now rather clear what i do
um i have um
uh
i have this expect i have this
polynomial uh in uh
leaf variables x
right i pick one of the leaf populations
and i apply my lifting rule
right
that will
get rid of the leaf node
and give me a polynomial
involving variables that are higher up
the tree
right
and so you just repeatedly do this
you keep each time
i pick a i pick a a
after i've lifted one node i can then
kill that edge i look i find a new leaf
variable keep on lifting i get back to a
poly to a polynomial in one variable ah
right
lifting all the way back to the root
and
by
ewan's theorem
uh the likelihood of r is proportional
to one over r
so my entire likelihood comes down to
this univariate integral e sub over
right that's what i do i just uh
i i take my count data
i take each possible pattern
i um apply this lifting formula i get
back to the root
um i do this univariate integral
numerically
so it's worth
um
comparing this
uh with daddy
um i don't want to do a detailed
comparison but um clearly we're still
working on much the same problem right
both both this work and daddy are
trying to compute likelihoods um the
um
the detail flavor though is completely
different
uh daddy uh likes continuous migrations
right um
i don't daddy wants um
uh
wants a small number of populations but
doesn't really care
if the count's um uh
sizes are rather large right because the
work is going on there um the sort of
working fluid if i could say for daddy
is directly the joint
um
the joint spectrum of allelic
probabilities and here this is all being
indirect right i know i don't get these
x's directly i'm integrating them out
all the time right so that's a different
thing
um so i'm
my my running fact times get bad if i
count data is very deep but um
well i think that's not true for daddy
but they don't get so bad if i have lots
of populations
right um that's a different entirely
different
entirely different deal
and um
uh i do think that some of the problems
i have are identical
to problems that that laura had and
daddy i mean carlos sitting in the front
row here um there were some difficulties
for me in convergence there are
especially difficulties in determining
what the right phylogeny is and that's
actually my main interest
i'm not so interested in getting the
parameters tight that would be nice but
i do would like to get the shape of the
graph roughly right if you haven't got
that right it's also nonsense really
um
all right so this is the this is sort of
um this is uh this is step one
and it's um it's machinery where um uh
you've got no new rotations
so what about new mutations
um i was quite puzzled by this for some
while but eventually i managed to work
out what three-year-old to be i think
so
now i've still got my i've got some
atomic event drifter
x goes to y
and
i'm interested in the event
that a mutation occurs
on um on this edge
and again f of y is a univariate
polynomial in y
and for technical reasons and it's
always true in practice
uh i want it divisible by y
and population size on this edge is n
prime where it was big n back at the
whole root
okay
so
um here's a theorem
um
the probability
of m
times the expected value of f
conditional on m is
first of all there's a factor here which
involves the population sizes
and then you've got this function q f
tau
which is this thing it's there's a
there's a term um involving
f of one
which is the um
which is which is uh yeah related to fit
which is related to the fixation
times the drift
and then this integral
where um we're going to calculate the
expected value
of f conditional on x
integrated over x
although um noticed that um this is sort
of a funny thing
because um the mutation actually
occurred on this edge
and i'm worrying about functions
involving
um uh what what didn't happen
right
because
there wasn't an allele frequency
x was all derived but nevertheless i can
mathematically consider what happens
when i do this
so
um this is this is a formula um which
may actually be new i mean i i someone
in the audience might tell me they've
seen this before but i i certainly have
not
um
and um uh i won't try and prove this
rigorously but i'm gonna i'm gonna
mumble how this happens
so
um
you imagine a phylogeny you've got x
goes to y and then you just got a
constant size population all the way
back to infinity here with the same size
of population as occurs on this edge
right just imagine this philogeny
and um now um
the um
event that a mutation occurs on this
edge
right
um uh has the the probab is the
probability that an event occurs
ancestrally somewhere
minus the probability that it occurs
ancestral to x
right you can just write it that way
right
and then you you work through what that
means
right and um that difference both those
things can then be calculated
right the expect the um uh uh theorem
tells you what you expect um if the if
uh um just the just given the mutation
occurs ancestrally somewhere um and um
my calculus
allows me to
work out the expected value of f uh
conditional on x that's the previous
case
and uh uh you get the answer you want it
it's this is almost a kind of physicist
argument there's a thing you want to do
and you construct
a situation
uh that isn't what happened but allows
you to do the calculations you want
right and that's good enough right
so that's a it's a
slightly curious thing
um
all right so you know assumptions about
whether the mutation is fixed or
segregating right it just arose on that
branch
yes
and um
you'll deal with the bookkeeping well so
let's just well i'm only going to mumble
about it really but really what happens
is we we keep on lifting up right and
now we get to a situation where y is a
leaf node
right well two things can happen first
of all there can be variables around
uh in my polynomial which are not y
right what that means uh uh genetically
is that there's um uh there are
populations
uh where um the allele uh cannot be
ancestral to why
right so that doesn't happen right right
if um if in other words if there's some
variable here that isn't why after
you've lifted up here um the um the
configuration you're looking at was did
not occur from a mutation on this edge
right so the only case of interest is
the wise unit is that the polynomial is
univariate right
and then i'm this then i'm telling you
how you calculate uh this quantity
probably the probably think times the
expectation right so what happens in the
big picture now
is that you would still want to
calculate the whole likelihood and
there's a whole bunch of scenarios
depending on whether the
mutation was polymorphic at the root or
on which edge it occurred and you can
add all these things up
right so that's this this is the new
ingredient you need uh if you're going
to have if you're going to have to deal
with love on mutations sort of a flux of
new mutations coming in at different
parts yeah but by ground rules on a
given base
the new mutation can only occur once in
the tree
right you just have to worry about where
it happened
okay
so
um
this is a calculus
that allows you to deal
with um at least in principle
arbitrary
count
joint allelic data on any admixture
graph
right
with um
and there are three kinds of variables
uh there are drift parameters on the
edges
there are admixture weights
and there are
population sizes
on edges where new mutations can occur
right
i think a
this is implicit in what everybody's
doing but it hasn't always been i think
terribly explicit
um
that
the population sizes
uh the drift is critical to everything
that's going on here
but the actual population sizes um are
not important at all unless new
mediations are arising
right so um
if you're trying to specify sort of
calendar time
and population size
but you haven't got any new mutations
occurring on stage the whole thing is
ridiculously over parameterized i mean
it doesn't make any sense right so you
don't so you may as well just think
about the drift all right
okay so now i want to in the last part
of the talk
i want to
um show you some data
and some new i some these miley new
ideas for thinking about this
um and this is actually
definitely overlapping with laura though
i i'm going to
i think talk it was a fairly small part
of lebron's talk and there's a larger
part of what i want to do
so what i want to say first of all if
you take nothing away from my talk
uh you should accept you should take
away this this picture and what it means
um
so what we're looking at here
is the polymorphic spectrum
in yoruba
right
um conditional
on
a um on a single archaic derived allele
that's either neanderthal or denisova
and um you get this
extremely symmetric
uh u-shaped curve
and um the first thing to say
is that there seems to be absolutely no
difference
between whether you condition on the uh
on a the denisova
uh
fossil or um or the or the other
neanderthal
but
that's actually um not quite the whole
story
because this is a conditional spectrum
and you could ask the probability
that yoruba is polymorphic
and turns out that that's very different
when you'd condition underneath the
neanderthal
yaruba's got a two and a half percent
smaller probability of being polymorphic
if you condition on denis of earth and
on neanderthal
um that's um uh
beyond
significant probability by 97.5 subtract
no you multiply by 97. about 0.97 for
the point of myself yeah um
so um this is really very striking fact
and in our recent paper
on the this is why it's
fantastic paper on
um uh
the altai neanderthal
um we look at this rather carefully
and argue that this is extremely strong
evidence
for what we call super archaic flow into
denisova
i think that there is some extremely uh
ancient uh gene flow into denisova
um
which we could perhaps loosely call homo
erectus who knows um
so there's a the supplementary paper
here um
david and i worked on this frontier
group worked on this monty's group
worked on this very hard
but i don't want to talk about what we
did there with in the interest in that
paper were always going on on the sort
of archaic part of the tree
so i want to think about what's going on
in the human modern human part of the
tree
so
the the fact that you get this same
uh conditional spectrum
um uh
i think uh must mean
that um
uh the um
uh the uh
conditional spectrum
at s at the split
when when uber
when ancestral urubala and ancestral
archaic split
um it can't matter
um uh
if your uber is polymorphic um if you're
polymorphic at that split time the
spectrum must have been the same at uh
whether whether you're conditioning
underneath or neanderthal oh there's no
way we're gonna get this complete match
up
yeah
um that's true
so you're okay i should say
that i'm trying i'm trying to here to
get a crude picture of what's going on
and
this will not be true
uh in absolute detail
right
and in fact for example as a an
indication the sort of problems i don't
want to talk about
we believe that there is very low level
west duration gene flow into eurasians
into europe i'm sorry there's west
duration gene flowing into yoruba at a
very low level um carrying some
neanderthal alleles
um with them
and
that's exactly what i don't want to talk
about it sort of i i'm trying to get the
big picture right and the so details are
going to be washed under the rug a bit
all right um
so um
furthermore the spectrum is extremely
close to symmetric
so why is that
again it's not exactly symmetric but all
right
so
if you remember
your well your in fact comes from
europe's theorem you've got two over x
as the um uh
the uh stationary distribution
and multiplied by x because we see a
derived allele you the polymorphic
spectrum should be flat at split time
under simple phylogenies
and i think when i thought about this
fairly hard
about the only way you're going to get
an approximately symmetric spectrum down
here is that's what happened
so
um
i think
that
the
spectrum at split time is extremely
close to uh to flat distribution
well if you remember if you think about
your diffusion theory polymorphic
spectra
that are uniform stay uniform
under constant populate under under
panmytic so if the spectrum if the
europa spectra ancestral europa spectrum
is flat at the archaic split time
and all you've got is panmyktic
making
since then
the spectrum has to stay flat
and i put it to you this is not a flat
spectrum
so this is already extremely powerful
evidence that there's got to be
something more complex going on and i
think the lava mentioned that he's
seeing um
evidence for ghost populations
and um
uh mike hammer and jeff wall is jeff is
jeff in the audience here i haven't seen
him though
it might be left pity oh i was hoping
he'd see this um but
my a couple of years ago mike hammer and
jeff wool used entirely different
methods uh haplobate haplotype based
methods uh claimed that there was um uh
ancient gene flow into into the yoruba
they weren't able to date it very
precisely and what i'm saying here is
that it seems to me that there's
overwhelming evidence that what you must
have had is a deep split and then merged
back in the yaruba lineage
but it's more recent than the archaic
human split
so i i like to say it's an ancient event
but not an archaic event
but
um
and um
the furthermore the the as you'll see
from the actual um uh parametric models
i'm going to write down i i'll just show
you one fit um the the effect the effect
is really pretty extreme um
uh all right
so um once you do that
um it's rather easy once you what you
allow yourself this
deep split emerge fitting the spectrum
is quite easy and the parameters are
poorly determined
which um i think is probably true for
everyone's techniques actually right i
um
uh i can fit this with many many models
that are different in detail but they
all have this deep split emerge
and here what i'm doing is i'm looking
at the aruba spectrum
i condition on a single head in yaruba
using david reich's um
slipper rays and denisova derived
and
get this is a good data on the feet you
can hardly tell a difference
all right so now here are two models um
one of the interests here is how does
the rest of your humanity fit into this
so
um tomorrow model a
um we have this deep split in yoruba
but the um
uh out of africa event only occurs on
one of the branches
right i mean you know what's the what's
the evidence that actually
the split emerge
are more ancient than out of africa
and the second one is you get a split
emerge in the aruba and then the out of
africa event is occurring after the
merge back these are two very very
different marbles
um notice that both of them have exactly
the same aruba spectrum because the the
okay
so and um
if you pick just a single french allele
um and try to fit these things i can fit
both both the models fit very very well
which is again a cautionary tale
that um phylogeny is not trivial to
determine
so finally i want to wind up
with a
new idea
which i think
which i think could be used
really by anyone working this era i
think it could probably be used by
lebron and and by uh carlos uh as group
in in using daddy
um
the
um suppose you've got any of these
models you've got a branch of b and then
you've got some phylogeny down here um
for um
eurations
which is occurring just independently of
whatever's going on down in africa
it's not not a very unusual situation
and suppose we have a rather suppose
we're going to study a fairly small
number of eurasian alleles
well
um and we're in a situation where we're
not having to worry about new mutations
notice that if our condition on your
uber polymorphic
and archaic derived
i absolutely don't have to worry about
new mutations because the mutations i'm
looking at are all very old
all right
so
so so let's suppose i'm just going to
consider three french chromosomes
okay and a whole bunch of yoruba
well
when you think about that when you go to
coalescent
um
you've got one two or three
distinct lines of descent at the branch
off point
okay and there's some probability
for for that
um which i'll call you i'll call you
right and um that probability and in
fact that event for how many lines of
descent i have when i coalesce back is
completely independent of the yoruba
phylogeny not to do with it right
um so
um
i'm going to
um
and but i can observe the probability of
j derived french alleles given k your
uber alleles
okay
and and so given k
given the aruba phylogeny i have some
probability p
for the allele frequency at the branch
off point
and so you just write down the the you
can just write down some trivial
equations here
and you see that this joint allele
spectrum for french
um and
french conditioned on the yoruba is just
these expectations
where the u's
are independent decay
right
and you've got this piece that you don't
know
but
where the dependence on k comes in but
the p can be calculated um using exactly
the calculus that we have
for example um uh you want to know um
probability of p and q well just attach
two notional alleles
um to the branch off point with no drift
and run your calculus or one daddy and
you will read off what the expected
value of of uh
of of pq is right so you can calculate
the uh the expectations uh in here the
coefficients of u can all be calculated
with the machine all you've got and that
will be true for the right be true for
for carlos is true for me
right and at that point um we can um
just run standard linear regression
uh to fit the ui
well that's actually very powerful
because what it means is that i just
want an aggression machine
which is instantaneous and i don't have
to worry about the detailed phylogeny on
the on the eurasian side right um uh the
um
so i found that i think this is quite a
strong idea and it allows me to think
about the phylogeny on the urban side
and not make detailed assumptions on the
eurasian side for small numbers of
alleles
so this is not going to work
if the
number of
number of alleles you're observing
on the eurasian side is large because
you start having to worry about all the
ways you can partition up in which is
growing exponentially but i think that
there's a lot of influence
that's important here that can be done
with quite small numbers
so um i did this
french
n equals three
for model b and model a and this is not
actually a very impressive looking
picture
what i'm showing you is normalized
residuals um for um yaruba frequency um
uh uh
conditioning on a head for zero through
20
and uh green is the model b and red is
model a you may not be very impressed
but actually um
these are normalized so that at random
um
the the the the mean value should be one
um we expect the actual mean of the
right to be a bit smaller than one
because we did a fit
right
if we knew truth it should be one but i
fit it so i'll do better than one
and um what i see is the model a i i
have a mean
a means of mean square residuals of more
than two and mod model b is less than
one and that's pretty decisive
so
yeah
shouldn't we be concerned about the
systematic pattern in the residuals
yeah well i told you
yeah you should i and i'm not writing
down the likelihood here
right
i'm just telling you
that the mean square residual is about
right for model b
and much too high for model a
right
and um the dependence is coming in from
all kinds of stuff
first of all
phylogeny is probably wrong right then
there's dependents in the original count
data
right
and so on
just because you've got
one model that is
less
terrible than the other model
that you've got systematic residuals
well i thought what i should what i
should the the problem is that i'm not
correctly modeling the covariance on the
residuals that is true and that's one of
the i did i began by saying this is a
work in progress yeah right no
absolutely and in fact um i i want to
come back to the my final slide i want
to come back to um
uh i want to come back to um
the problems which which are many um
so here's the uh here's a fitted model
uh model b
um
and uh um it's really rather an extreme
model
though i don't um i'm um i see this
denise of a split uh my current
apparatus
on this data does not allow me to
estimate this particular drift right um
these are um drift parameters um in
normalized time times a thousand
right
so um on one branch i have deep deep
drift
right
um with my many ma a great deal of stuff
fixes out on this edge
um i have extremely shallow
drift on this other branch
and then um 60 40 mixing
right
not much happens
on the you will branch after the merge
because we actually have every reason to
think that in for the last
hundred thousand years anyway the aruba
population effective population side has
been quite big
and this is the art of africa event
so this is of course
the ghost populations
that are being
that mike hammer and um laura
have seen
um
it's um
and if model b is right uh this stuff is
is going to be ancestral to um to all
humans except maybe from sun and i'm
looking at the sun right now and i'm not
sure what um i'm still not quite sure
what's going on there
so um
so here's what i think is some of the
things which are missing in the
methodology
so
the first one i think actually the most
important
is testing for model adequacy
i
think
with respect to carlos and laura
nobody really knows how to do that i
don't know i mean the problem is
actually carlos said it you do a fit
right it's this fit is better than that
fit
right but is it good enough right
is the issue that's too easy to test you
know simulate data and see what's going
to disappear it's not a hard thing
it's larger than what you would expect
no i i with respect i don't agree
um in fact
the um uh this is a problem of
this is a standard problem statistics
let me give you let me give you a
trivial example
um you have univariate data
and you decide you're gonna fit a normal
distribution right and it has a mean
zero variance one very closely right and
you get happy right and you generate
other simulated data and find that you
have um uh that you're gonna you'll do
something if it doesn't
the point is there can be gross features
in your data that show conclusively
you're completely wrong right so that's
why you fit the model to one aspect of
the data and you test with another so
one thing we do in the daddy paper for
example is we fit to the joint allele
frequency spectrum
and then look at whether the model
predicts the patterns and the decay of
ld which is a statistic we we have no we
make no use of the ld information yeah
and then
um for some models for example you can
say oh boy i did a terrible job of
predicting the decay of ld and this does
a much better job yeah and for example
my personal opinion this is an unsolved
problem i mean you know i mean i think
statisticians have thought a
tremendous amount about ways that you
can do model selection and model yes and
validation
and in complicated situations it's an
unsolved problem maybe we should talk
about this online uh offline but um it's
even i mean i'll give you i'll tell you
um i mean i'll be able to make a
somewhat extreme statement but i have
actually checked with probably the world
authorities on this
it's an unsolved problem how to test
whether multivariate data is
multivariate normal
there is no agreement as to how to do
this
sign estimators are a problem right you
know we can think about it's really hard
so um
i do not know how to build for lodgings
and again i think this is not um
uh this is related of course
right
i've got a phylogeny i can certainly
test if somebody else's phylogeny looks
better than mine
but
you know
yeah
is the day what is the data really have
i got it right or is that you know is uh
um is there something that tells me that
you know it's wrong or um what other
phylogeny is possible here
right i mean there's a you know so i
think this is hard um the data
um uh in spite of david reich's and
others efforts
the data is not as good as i would like
by the time you're looking at many
populations the data gets thin
and
it's
it becomes problematic
the um
local maxima can be difficult but i
think i i suspect carlos went into that
too actually to some extent you know the
convergence stuff is a real problem yeah
yeah
and the bigger
the more data you have the finer the
grid has to be so you can compute the
likelihood better i mean
more data makes the problem much much
more targeted actually um
i i i my thinking of that is maybe we
can inch up on the problem and you'll be
if you're if you use less data your
models are coarser
and that actually may help you for
convergence so you kind of simulated a
kneeling kind of a press yeah you start
getting into an area
and finally in real world
uh you do a double back mutations you do
have sequencing data you do have the
ancestral allele being misidentified
and
this stuff doesn't do any of that
properly yet
um so um i've had many this is only a
very partial list of of my uh
collaborators david reich of course um
sriram has been a great help with me
here and he's uh
um part of this workshop uh monty and
eric have worked on related fields
and um
i talked a great deal about data that
came from the neanderthal denisova
consortium which of course
led up by samantha
so and finally um i would like to put up
an advertisement
uh david's david like islam has is um
has a um a whole bunch of
parented postdocs who scare me because
they're so strong
and we have zero graduate students
and i would like to fix this so thank
you very much
monty
uh i think it's model b
where the the admixture event yes that
one uh
takes place before the split of the
arubans and the french make some strong
predictions about the french
conditional spectrum as well yes i
haven't really looked it's it's
i'm i'm looking at this um it's
not as clear
because if you look deeply first of all
you've got to worry about the archaic
admixture coming in which
has been predictable which is
but it also um
the um
the the the
you know the bottleneck sort of
bottleneck sort of wipes out memory to
some extent right so a deep bottleneck
means you can't go back through it
really because
this is such an extreme event that
perhaps we can do something and i
haven't really studied that
yeah
uh yeah andy
related to um i'm not
okay i'm i am moderately confident
right i mean um i um i really think the
residuals of the model a
are too large right i mean even when i
look at one of one of my boxes um
i've already got two sigma and that's
not you know it's it's not ridiculous
so this is true under the wrong model
under the correct model may be the
residuals
well if model a with some refinements i
don't know
i might be okay
right
but that's that's correct yeah so i'm
not entirely confident this is
definitely defending myself this is
definitely work in progress right
and i've noticed i haven't published it
um
yeah
that's it any more questions
well i i i don't want to lay your lunch
anymore